Where will we go i don't know i don't know
anywhere that means elise
will protector i suppose oh
you really meant it yeah we
will need a cape and a mask
no no i think you got that covered we're good no
I don't love you. You know i mean i like you
a lot i really like you but love you know it's uh
yeah you know
nah of course eddie you must fight it
hey eddie
you too love me no i do not you do you, no. You do.
Spider-man is a psychopath wielding powers he has
no right to possess trying to pass himself off
as a hero well let me tell you
something kid you're no hero
Welcome back everyone this would be my new venom
let there to be carnage alternate ending and post
credit scene there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs so we'll break it all down also talk about
how this is connected to spider-man no way home
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's a bunch
of spider-man stuff happening before the end of
the year big spoiler warning if you have not seen
venom let there be carnage yet i still think there
are like one or two countries where it still
has not been released we'll be talking about
the post-credits scene and then a lot of what's
happening during spider-man no way home but sony
just released a totally different ending scene
of the movie and then also revealed an alternate
version of the post-credits scene with a different
tom hall on scene so in this alternate ending
scene they still end the movie with venom eating
both the carnage symbiote and cletus cassidy
separately the carnage symbiote got separated from
cletus using the same trick with the church bell
during the venom origin story from the comics
with spider-man using the church bells to get rid
of the venom symbiote they even did a version of
that during the tobey mcguire spider-man 3 movie
so the version in venom let there be carnage was
kind of like a remix of that also a via rod was
a producer on that original spider-man 3 tobey
mcguire movie and he's a producer on venomous
debbie cards so it makes sense that they would do
some toby moments for this new movie the big twist
with the new version in venomotherby karna's
though is that venom actually pushes shriek
off the rooftop of the cathedral banging her
into the church bell like ringing the church bell
using shriek but as she fell to her death below in
the ground she starts screaming with the biggest
sonic scream you've ever heard destroying most of
the upper level of the cathedral and damaging the
carnage symbiote so badly that it separated from
cletus giving venom the time he needed to just
pick it up grab it and eat it whole like a tasty
snack if it wasn't clear eating other symbiotes
gives them a giant power boost so they had this
whole joke about him eating chickens during the
movie and that not being nutritious enough like
not getting that brain chemical that it needed
because chickens brains were so small when venom
eats the carnage symbiote he gets a massive power
boost it's way more nutritious quote unquote than
eating an actual person's brain so he is good to
go on energy for a good long while but they still
wind up running away to what seems like a tropical
foreign country to escape the police because
they're still wanted by the law because of all
the vigilante stuff that had been going on in san
francisco recently that's part of why detective
patrick mulligan hated eddie brock so much because
they've been trying to find out who was behind all
these random attacks on criminals and he started
to suspect eddie because he always seemed to be
connected to all the vigilante events around the
city like why am i always finding you connected
all these crazy things that are happening and then
eddie also screwed him on the cletus cassidy case
right after detective mulligan told him not to so
patrick mulligan even though now it seems like he
has his own mutant powers at the end of the movie
would arrest eddie and venom on site if they
ever saw him again in this universe thankfully
doctor strange and spider-man have him covered
when you botched that spell where you wanted
everyone to forget the peter parker spider-man
we started getting some visitors big fat yank into
the main mcu universe the reason why they went to
the beach in this scene is just because the venom
symbiote had said one of its wishes was to feel
sand between his toes even though they joke about
it not having toes like you don't have toes what
are you talking about but you get the metaphor so
it's eddie trying to be less selfish by listening
to what the symbiote wants and giving it to him
he literally mentions venom lethal protector which
is the name of the comic book run that inspired
the first venom movie and sort of the whole vibe
of this version of the character an anti-hero who
only kills bad guys one of the funny twists though
of the spider-man post-credits scene is that he
now thinks that spider-man is a villain sort of
setting up spider-man versus venom their whole odd
couple back and forth joking about eddie not being
in love with venom is just a callback to all the
other scenes in the movie when other people or the
symbiote itself reference their relationship like
ann wang made several jokes about the two of them
having a really messed up relationship but if it
wasn't clear eddie is not in love with venom like
he's not lying here even though they're joking
about it so it's sort of like banner in the hulk's
relationship when it evolves to the point where
they can work together to form professor hulk
instead of each of them fighting for control of
his body i know there's all kinds of questions
about hulk's arm in the she-hulk trailer well not
that normal these transformations are triggered by
anger and fear don't make me angry you wouldn't
like me when i'm angry it was still on the sling
during the shangxi post-credits scene but in the
she-hulk trailer his arm seems totally fine don't
worry we'll get those she-hulk episodes early next
year so i'll talk more about that when we get more
she-hulk footage there's a lot of questions about
the marvel phase 4 timeline and where all these
different series and all the movies sort of fit
in with each other there's a lot of stuff that's
overlapping right now like eternal spider-man
no way home the venom let there be carnage post
credit scene doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness when i do new trailer videos i'll
address that like where each new movie fits into
the timeline but in the alternate version of the
venom let the carnage post credit scene with tom
holland they were going to have a spider-man no
way home scene that played out in a very different
way originally what they had wanted to do was have
a scene where venom actually sees tom hall and
spider-man on the street like in the flesh instead
of just seeing a video of j jonah jameson yelling
about him in the theatrical cut we heard the venom
symbiote trying to tell eddie about its origin
story let me tell you about my race it's sort of
like a hive mind that exists across many different
universes that's why when the venom symbiote
seemingly recognized spider-man a lot of people
are like wait a minute maybe he's tapping into the
memories from the topher grace spider-man 3 venom
symbiote remembering another version of spider-man
like this looks familiar the same way the doctor
octopus in the spider-man no way home trailer
thinks that it's the tobey maguire spider-man
in the iron spider costume until he d-masks him
and says wait a minute you're not peter parker
you're not peter parker this doesn't mean that
they're going to bring topher grace's venom back
but it is a funny reference back to that character
like i said the same producers on toby maguire
spider-man 3 that did that version of venom are
also the ones who are producing the new venom
movies so of course they're going to include
little easter eggs and references back to those
movies but the idea is that the producers actually
wanted to bring tom holland back and have him
film a new scene as his mcu spider-man for the
venom let the be carnage post credit scene and if
it wasn't clear the video that venom is watching
of j jonah jameson is actually a brand new scene
that they filmed for this post-credits scene
like if you went back and you watched spider-man
no way home the video that venom is watching
is totally different from the spider-man far
from home post-credit scene so they actually
had jk simmons come back and film new footage
for the venom version of the scene and there's
a rumor that they also did the same thing for the
morbius movie like there'll be some sort of jay
jonah jameson scene in the morbius movie where
he's doing something similar i've already done
a couple of new morbius trailer videos because
there were so many questions about the different
easter eggs from every single spider-man movie
ever there's andrew garfield spider-man easter
eggs there's tobey maguire spider-man easter eggs
and tom holland mcu easter eggs all sort of mixed
in this really weird way just making people wonder
what they're actually doing inside the morbius
movie it raised so many questions but now the
movie seems so much more interesting i'll add a
link for those videos in the description below but
the footage of tom holland that you're watching
here in this post credit scene is actually just
footage that they already had from no way home
so this venom scene is meant to be happening
during the events of spider-man no way home
but he's still meant to be in a foreign country
like he's still in this tropical country where
the beach was that he was hiding out in so he's
not in the new york city area when spider-man no
way home is happening it in the alternate version
of the venomotherby carnage post-credits scene
they weren't going to have venom interacting with
spider-man on screen or anything like that he was
just going to see spider-man from a distance but
it was going to be spider-man in the flesh i think
they made the right call i don't think they would
have made the version that we saw in theaters any
better like venom seeing a video of tom hall
and spider-man did exactly what it needed to do
tell you that venom had been teleported to the mcu
thank you very much doctor strange and spider-man
and by him saying bad guy at the screen is just
meant to be a call back to the lethal protector
mantra right now watching this video venom
thinks that spider-man is a villain because he's
believing what j jonah jameson is saying and
now he's going to try and take spider-man down
but you have to remember that this is happening
when reality is sort of crumbling around them so
like is the events of spider-man no way home play
out and you see reality tearing all around doctor
strange and things going crazy that's when this
venom scene is supposed to be happening doctor
strange says in the trailer we started to get some
visitors venom is one of those visitors it's just
that we probably won't see him in spider-man
no way home until some kind of post credit
scene moment or a quick scene at the very end of
the film so if you have any requests or any big
questions about what's happening with the future
of spider-man the future of venom just write it
below in the comments and i'll add to my future
bonus videos we'll get some more spider-man no
way home trailers soon too everyone click here to
learn about those weird phantom scenes of andrew
garfield in the spider-man no way home trailer
and click here for my full trailer breakdown
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!